[Music]
joining me now is Victor Davis Hansen
Hoover institution senior fellow Victor
um there's an opportunity that
Republicans I think need to take
advantage of here um as Biden sees his
own base turning against him but you see
there is a push to Lurch back to the
establishment and the proar Coalition of
the Republican party as
well yeah I think CA Harris had it
absolutely backwards all these issues
the borderers
uh the trans issue with biological males
competing in in women's
sports um
inflation they all offend inner city
blacks Hispanics and now they've
alienated over the Israel question
Jewish the Jewish community and they can
they can get away with this Laura
historically when they have a hard left
base and they can veneer it over with a
very rhetorical mifis Barack Obama or
Bill Clinton they get away with it but
otherwise when they have a George
McGovern or Jimmy Carter it doesn't work
and that left becomes more pronounced
and that's what Joe Biden is he's a
force multiplier because of his
cognitive problems and really his
meanness his corruption problems he's a
force multiplier of this Division and
we're starting to see now this W Gaza
really tore this scab off and we're
seeing a putrid wound of what the
Democratic party is it's Pro the basis
let's face it it's Pro Hamas it's Pro
open borders it's Pro Ban gas engines
and natural gas stoves and that doesn't
appeal to Middle Class People it only
appeals to the very wealthy B Coastal
Elite and the subsidized poor and they
have a real problem because they can't
paper it over with a guy like Joe Biden
he's he's uh as I said Jimmy Carter and
George McGovern rukes so it gives
enormous opportunity for a populist
Republican party to appeal to these
disaffected voters if they can unite
around a candidate that can do that
they'll win and they'll win
overwhelmingly well over at MSNBC you'll
be shocked to know Victor that the
Elites from the you know Council on
Foreign Relations those types um they're
panicking that America actually might
move back to focusing on America First
Watch this we've gone from Al America
First under Donald Trump to Alliance
first under Joe Biden this is a
partnership based foreign policy if
Donald Trump were to come back suddenly
these Partnerships would all be placed
risk the foreign policy implications of
this election are arguably going to be
greater than any election in modern
history Victor what what are all those
alliances have I missed the huge amount
of money that Europe is putting into the
war in Ukraine uh if I miss
that they don't understand that the
world is being remade before our very
eyes Laura we're not an ally of turkey
anymore turkey really doesn't belong in
NATO we see that gutter is working hand
uh hand and glove with Hamas and yet we
have a ccom base in Gutter and they keep
talking about offensive operations and
disproportionate use of force in Ukraine
and that's exactly what they tell the
Israelis not to do so they're incoherent
they never tell us we're going to have X
amount of billions of dollars for these
programs uh for foreign aid and some of
it's probably arguably necessary
especially with Israel but they never
tell us where the money's coming from
we're going to cut here suspend here or
we're going to tax they never do it's
always we're going to print more money
for this agenda and then we look at it
and we say well how did libia turned out
how did Syria turn out what is why is
turkey threatening to attack our Ally
Israel what is gutter doing with centcom
and then it's working with and they have
yeah and with the K they never say
they're sorry they never say they're
sorry they'll never say they're going to
learn from their mistakes it's trust us
and we don't trust them anymore Victor
great to see you voters don't yeah the
voters don't and both base of both
parties thank you hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-hosts Harris
vulner and Kaylee mechineni on
outnumbered every weekday at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights